Speaker 1: 36 year old divorced grandmother and
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Boebert appeared
on a panel yesterday congressional hearing
about the high cost of prescription drugs,
an important issue. And she declared during this
hearing that the reason she had a third child is
because birth control was too expensive. So she
opted to leave the pharmacy without paying for
the prescription. I guess having unprotected sex
leading to this third child that she ultimately
had. Now, there are factual inaccuracies here.
There are moral conundrums here. Let's listen to
the clip first and then we're going to discuss it.
Speaker 3: But do you see that patients leave
their prescriptions at pharmacies because they
can no longer pay for it? They absolutely do. In
my pharmacy, yes. That happens.
Speaker 1: More than.
Speaker 3: Should make anyone come. I actually
have a fun little story. My staff is probably
going talk to me about this later. But I
left a prescription at a pharmacy once.
I went to get birth control and I was there
at the counter and went to pay for it. And
the price was very, very high. I said, Wow, is
this a36 month prescription? No, ma'am, this is
one month. And I said, It's cheaper to have a kid.
And I left it there. And now I have my third son,
Kaiden Boebert. And so I'm actually was I was
turned out to be a really great thing, but I
personally experienced that when times were tough.
But thank you so much for your indulgence there
and talk to the team about that comment later.
Speaker 1: Oh, my team is going to get me in
trouble because I told an insane story. So
there's a lot here. There is. There is a
lot here. There is Lauren Boebert legislative
hypocrisy. There are the factual inaccuracies
as well. So first and foremost, Lauren
Boebert has been a staunch opponent of
abortion and reproductive rights. She's voted
against expanding access to contraception for
millions of Americans who need it and potentially
are in the position she was once in where paying
for the birth control is expensive. So she
has been someone who, if this story is true,
she understands how difficult that can be. And she
has voted against making it easier to access birth
control for millions of Americans. She also seems
completely oblivious to the fact that raising a
kid is way more expensive than paying completely
out of pocket for the birth control pills,
which with most insurance plans now are actually
free anyway. But forget about that for a second.
The research I've done suggests that out of
pocket birth control is about 50 bucks a month.
50 bucks a month. The estimated cost of raising a
child to age 18 most recently was $233,000. Now,
that's a six year old number. Inflation might
make it even higher at this point in time. That
depends on a lot of different things, including
the standard of living and geographical location,
all these different things. If you pay the
50 bucks a month or $600 per year for birth
control out of pocket, even over 18 years, if you
were on out-of-pocket birth control for 18 years,
that's ten grand compared to at least $233,000
to raise a kid. So what she's saying is also
very stupid. And it actually makes me wonder, did
she really believe that? Is Lauren Boebert so bad
at either math or reality that when she saw, wow,
it's going to be 50 bucks for these birth control
pills, Did she really do some math that came out
with her thinking it's cheaper to have a kid and
to pay the costs of having a kid for 18 years? I
don't know. It's a level of stupidity that really
is shocking. And then there's the moral aspect
here as well. She's essentially saying, I didn't
even want this third kid, but I ended up having
this third kid because I had unprotected sex,
because I couldn't afford the birth control. And
therefore I didn't even actually want this kid,
although she's saying he's a good kid. I like
the kid and reminds me of producer Lewis,
who once said, If I accidentally had a
kid, I'd probably love the kid. It seems
like she ends up loving her kid, but she's saying
essentially that she didn't want that kid either,
which I know is not. There are many
parents who would have stories like this,
but the funny little story that Lauren Boebert
told is an extraordinarily disturbing example
of how out of touch she is with the
reality of what it cost to raise a kid,
what it costs to pay for birth control,
completely, seemingly morally disconnected
from what I would call a responsibility that she
has as a member of Congress to okay, you know,
of a. Problem that you experienced. You
could vote to prevent other people from
having that very same problem. But she doesn't.
Instead, she votes to make it more difficult to
access that very same thing. Truly and absolutely
disgusting. And also seemingly a clueless person.